thank you to our sponsor native
deodorant native creates simple safe and
effective products that people use in
the bathroom every day bata Bureau is
formulated with faul aluminum parabens
and talkin uses ingredients found in
nature such as coconut oil shea butter
and tapioca starch and native is never
tested on aminals making the switch to
aluminum free deodorant does not mean
having a sacrifice on product
performance native has over 9000
five-star reviews it comes in a variety
of scents for men and women such as
coconut and vanilla lavender and rose
and cucumber and mint
they also have an unscented formula and
a baking soda free formula for those
with sensitivities for 20% off of your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code ot or during
checkout there's no risk to try a native
offers free shipping as most returns and
exchanges in the USA again for 20% off
your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code OTR
ever since Roth record during checkout
Thank You native three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
when we talk about whatever we shade and
while we're on this patreon thing I also
have a patreon shameless plug I'm sorry
Girl Interrupted go check it out for
exclusive interviews and it gets pretty
wild I definitely say [ __ ] and talk
about a lot of things that pertain to
that word who is your favorite interview
you have ever done you know I just had
Maurice Bernard on and it was like
really oh oh
who is Maurice Bernard he is sonny
corinthos on General Hospital he's been
in that gig forever
oh that good yeah and so my mom's like a
huge fan but he's been he was one of the
first people to talk about being bipolar
like as an actor like he talked about an
Oprah in like 2001 or like it like a
long time ago and so that was so ahead
of his time he didn't have to do it yeah
and he talks about his breakdowns and
like how he processes everything how he
manages so proper is a probably good
outlet for him
yeah What did he say What did he say
that was like very insightful oh I never
thought of that there was so many gems
on there that it's it's hard to honestly
pick one but he has this thing in be
state of mind calm where he is Sunday
sessions he like in for free you can
just go on there and like look at him
just talk about his mental health and
what he's gone through and right now
he's doing this series where he talks
about his three breakdowns he's had like
three big major psychotic break downs
and I know you guys can't relate to this
but oh you know I don't know that it was
just nice to talk to someone who's been
in a psych ward and like just normalizes
oh wow you're talking about real
breakdown yeah like it was like yeah
yeah and the psych ward - for what let's
take a great field trip
we laughed that everyone in there funny
that's really really really funny I'm
sure you were the head of your class and
they can't blame you because you and
Sonny Corinthos still alive on the show
he is Andy's character has bipolar -
they wrote it in you know - the
character so I thought it was really
cool and he could have lost his job like
imagine back in the day when no one
really knew what bipolar was and like
you come out about that on your like a
working actor usually you want to hide
that [ __ ] it's scary yes I see one
stable yeah and he just owned it and I
just thought that was really cool
years ago I did improv with the entire
cast of General Hospital and except for
sunny except for him we did it for a
charity and it was [ __ ] fun because
you you you get to just bring them in
make them look good and then they're
getting last cuz everyone knows them so
you just like to give them gifts the
whole time do they know how to play they
all know how to play
no but they but that's what I mean you
can you can really take anyone throw
them in the scene with experienced
improvisers who are just gonna give them
good [ __ ] to like put the ball on the
tee for them and yet you know I wish I
had that when I did improv they were all
just we weren't on TV shows you know
through you that's the only reason why
we didn't succeed are you roping me into
this I know you did improv for a little
bit did you not I I did yeah I'm
actually still like I take a class every
year just liked for funsies but
no I was there like a performing team or
anything I didn't stand it I thought you
tried it for like a hot minute um well
what life did ya like I used to go to a
lot of improv shows because I was like
dating an improviser but it wasn't like
I that wasn't my cup of tea
gotcha girl but I do a lot of like
improv classes yeah you've got to do
them it's fun to like learn the
structure of it mm-hmm what did you do
improv it have you done in fact I well
when I was like 16 I lied about my age
to get in the adult classes at The
Groundlings oh cool so I started there
and then I did second city and I did the
writing program there and then I did use
CP afterwards but I never got like I
never had teams and stuff but I wasn't
like a part of one and we just like
performed all the time cuz like it was
so cliquey and everyone was trying to
upstage each other or three that's the
only thing to is like if you're in a
good team it's like really cool when the
teams have good group mind and like
everyone's on the same page it makes the
show really funny but if you're like
coming from a class and like you're
trying to assemble like some half-assed
team it just wasn't really fun for me
because it was like everyone's trying so
hard and yeah it didn't feel fun
it's like desperate hour I would leave a
show being like I feel I want to die
right now I know it's it's like a bad
commercial audition but in front of
everybody
yeah especially during like the end of
class you know the end of class like a
showcase yeah yeah and then like whoever
brought the most family members he's
trying to like really impress all the
friends and they're like oh this guy's
just ruining the scene and as like dad
though I feel like almost like a very
miniaturised rock star
yeah to like those eight people like
supporting him from work or whatever oh
my gosh that's so funny
it's pretty funny how many people did
you bring or were you the person that
ever you didn't bring anyone I think she
came Joe came did you laugh at all yeah
yeah I try to be the loudest laughs did
you laugh even when it was just yeah
yeah just go to like all my stand-up
shows and then get to like hear the joke
like a million
would still laughing oh that's sweet
that's importantly sweet that's what you
want yeah why did you stand it for just
a little bit I was just like I was a
YouTube comedian at the time and then no
one really gave youtubers props and I'm
like a very like [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] and pay my dues that the person
I'm going to stand up so I just dis
stand up like for a little bit did you
hate the scene I actually really enjoyed
the art of it I just didn't like that if
they told me I was gonna go up but then
a bunch of famous people come in I get
pushed to 11 and then since I'm trying
to do this whole YouTube schedule thing
like you just [ __ ] my whole night up I
didn't really like that part of it I can
totally relate you have to like be part
of the social scene yeah like to really
like if you don't hang out then they're
like it's like the Pomona's want to
bring you back just because I want to
hang out but even if I killed it doesn't
really matter if they like kind of play
the game
yep that's impromptu man I was directly
told to like you're not you know what
you want to know why you're not on the
hell team it's cuz you don't hang on I
was like I can't I gotta [ __ ] work
yeah and it's just like I just hate
nighttime stuff I hate hanging out I
remember you telling me that on the
podcast we do like I hang breakfast like
I would totally be down for like some
brunches being that social see yeah yeah
but yeah everything's so late at night
I'm like usually like nighttime yeah
daytime comedy stuff I know but that's
what I'm saying it doesn't fit like I am
good at doing the show part and then I
would just leave because I can't just
hang like I get drained by people trying
to talk to me at bars late at night like
I would rather I don't have any energy
at that point morning person and I just
didn't like the food at birds and that's
where everyone UCB I was like oh god I
can't hang because I food you couldn't
go to the Scientology Center
nobody wanted to I just don't I didn't
like cuz you have to do all the
self-promotion like I have some very
awesome loyal fans but some of them can
get a little too aggressive and a little
you know yeah they feel kind of entitled
you know you guys have all the live
events and stuff like some people are
just a little too pushy you know and
especially in that environment like the
doesn't give a [ __ ] you know they don't
they're not like looking out for the
comics there's just like one have a
drink and they want their set time cuz
they're all comics trying to make it to
so that's what I didn't really like
about it and also I just felt like that
it got to a point
it just was a little toxic for me I was
like I have to constantly hear all this
negativity and comments and everything
else and then you're not right for this
you're not right for that and it's just
you have to kind of deal with the
rejection if you're not like tight with
the people and all that stuff I was like
you know what I'd rather just get like a
disgusting dick pic from wherever the
hell it is and be told I'm this letter
or [ __ ] instead of having to deal with
all that and do all my hair and makeup
and then go and then just get like
harassed anyway wait you get harassed
well like yeah the other comics are
trying to hook up with you the Booker's
are trying to like what you know work it
because they think that you're a
desperate for a spot and you're like no
I'd rather make it like a YouTube video
or an Instagram video or anything else
imagine sucking dicks you get a five
minutes spot on a comedy night that's so
depressing
yeah girls have it tough it's not yeah
and if they guys try to totally take
advantage of it it's just so like oh and
not like it so I'm glad that I quit you
don't do you did stand-up before um do
anymore my last show was an anti
Valentine's Day show this year speaking
of I sucked five dicks so I could get 15
minutes at the haha cafe November 18th
at sports birthday if you want to
celebrate Bart's birthday with us she
remembers everything that's very good
really yeah I remember everyone that
importance birthday yeah I thought so
remember since birth I remember actually
had no text message nothing but it's
okay text I actually have never heard
your birthday I don't I don't know if I
hear it right now I will remember it
forever September 26 I'll remember
forever
thank you said February girl no I said
my last show you know what's weird
though as I I thought you were over go
it what I thought you were Virgo and I'm
disappointed I'm a Libra I'm on a cusp
of a Virgo
why is my sign pissing you off it's not
pissing me off I just I I had September
in my head just thought you were a girl
in the beginning of a Sid Timbre
I hate it Nikki vember I hate your month
to August
yeah it's stuck why because it's your
month you could you know to me but I
can't do that man yeah you know that's
kind of how this for me [ __ ] is
happening here
great I mean I'm gonna remember that
what's my birthday she just thought I
know when your birthday is what it's in
November yep November 30 second no it's
it's I want to say here let me guess
this [ __ ] all right it's out of the
twelve to the 17th or the 15th you
missed it every time you know I am good
at something what are you good at making
things wrong okay nice that's very good
yeah thank you
expert level if I tell you right now you
will you remember forever yes November
2nd next time I see you oh I can't
forget that because of a somber reason
but I'll remember it okay yeah yeah cool
well now we know everyone's birthday
yeah no I know everybody's birthday here
it's the day before Greg's birthday Greg
the guy that died those may explain all
the lines a bit Wilder he was a love
your life no Jesus he's one of my
training I talked about this before
maybe they weren't Oh were they not here
yeah yeah what I haven't done jakey news
with you I know I know it's our first
time ever doing this together yeah my
second tour
thank you for tolerating yeah can you
tell the trans 3 game you got her
daughter member yeah oh he was filming
content and all the fitness guys
yeah Greg foot yeah yeah so he was
coming content he was run over the train
mm-hmm Burbank you trying to obviously
get a train on camera yeah he'd film
there before so he had this way up
energy drink that he was promoting and
so like he had this Superman like you
know Superman how he like out runs a
train so that's what he was doing but
then he flipped on the train tracks
my god and then they trade me with her
reviewable yeah the whole film crew and
everything saw it and they had to pick
up his like body early traumatic when
did that happen
2015 right after I found out my husband
was cheating on me and stuff it actually
knows right
yeahwe knows it was January and then in
the next month I found all that stuff ok
you said he was your boyfriend my so I
was married when he died I was married
when he died I he was the last guy I
dated before he got married and I was on
and off with him since I was 17 so like
we broke up in July of 2013 and then
August I met my my ex-husband who was
like the rebound guy and then I got
engaged within two months cuz I was like
oh this is the one don't do that don't
marry the one don't marry someone
because you like in two months of
knowing or whatever that's like too much
don't do change commercials either yeah
dude don't [ __ ] do it that's hard
that one's hard I can't laugh with that
no I mean that's just rough dude his
parents never liked me it was like dude
the second they asked about like the dad
oh [ __ ] I met the mom twice if the mom
did not want to remember either time the
dad asked me about my relationship with
my dad and then like have you ever had a
conversation with someone where they
stopped talking to you in the middle of
your conversation because they don't
agree with you oh you're still trying to
explain yourself and then they're just
like oh like they moved on I was like
okay well I'm not gonna win this
audience I got it all right
they had this girl that they wanted him
to marry they were like pushing on him
and he was so not into it like at all
here's the fun it was not fun but it's a
interesting story so he didn't like her
boobs cuz they like flopped everywhere
cuz they were like super big and real
like Kate Upton but when she was
pregnant so she had them lifted she had
plastic surgery for him she was healing
from the surgery when he died so at the
funeral her tits looked amazing that's
all you know this at the funeral there
was a lot of guy my sister went with me
and there was so many guys that she
hooked up with that were there and it
was just like they kept coming up to her
and I was like
oh my gosh so many spray-tanned then my
hairdresser was getting kind of turned
on because there are a lot of Fitness
people there yeah so like between my
sister and my hairdresser at the funeral
yeah I get it cuz it's a lot of emotions
I was just had a funeral I got horny
yeah we did have sex we did that nice
accent something about that can bring
that out in people a funeral but then it
was like you're vulnerable it's like
your emotions in your vulnerable you
like I care about this person along I
appreciate that my god are you saying
that you're pregnant
no I mean I could be tested or anything
oh okay
really really should have an excuse like
I'm just getting fat right now you know
like I'm on this new thyroid education
I'm gaining away I was there earlier
this year I mean for the past three
years I had a thing in my intestines I
finally had found out what it was that
was like making me bloated every single
day and then like the fat stuff you lost
weight what did you do I went in a
minute fasting and I went on the low
fodmap diet to get rid of the thing
while I was taking anti microbials to
get rid of bacteria what do you think
what was the thing it was SIBO small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth yeah so
I had to take anti microbials and then
while you're doing that like certain
foods will feed the bacteria so you have
to be on this really strict diet and
then I was intermittent fasting too so
that it kind of like starves the
bacteria while they're getting killed by
the thing are you good now yeah I think
so I've been like pretty much on back to
normal diet like and not having an
intermittent fast for the past like two
months I tell everyone I'm fasting when
I just like need to cook and I haven't
cooked it and I have any food on my own
fasting but it really yeah it should get
better but you just say that well it
sounds better
[Music]
[Music]